إذاً ، ما يمكنك
رؤيته في فيديو البث المباشر هذا
هو أنه يمكنك مشاهدة العديد من الدبابات
والمركبات المدرعة عبر الحدود
خلال فترة زمنية كبيرة على
الأقل لمدة دقيقة أو دقيقة ونصف من
تلك المركبات تتحرك  عبر الحدود
ومن ثم لدينا تلك المعلومات التي
تشير إلى أن هذا هو عبور الحدود
بين أوكرانيا وبيلاروسيا وأن
هذه القوات تأتي الآن من
بيلاروسيا وهذا أمر رائع حقًا
لأنني كنت في الواقع مع تلك
القوات ذاتها أه الأسبوع الماضي فقط عندما كانوا  كانوا
يجرون تدريبات واسعة النطاق
مع القوات الروسية داخل
بيلاروسيا ، وكان احتمال
غزو بيلاروسيا دائمًا
أمرًا
حذرنا منه وسألت هذا السؤال بالذات ، لا توجه
إلى بيلا الروسي القوي ألكسندر
لوكاشينكو فقط لإعطائك فكرة عن
بعض الأكاذيب والمعلومات المضللة
التي انتشرت قبل
ذلك وضحك علي وقال انظر هل
تعتقد حقًا أننا ذاهبون
غزو أوكرانيا ومن الواضح الآن أه بعد حو
لي أسبوع واحد فقط بعد ذلك بقليل ، نر
أن هذا على ما يبدو هو بالضبط ما
حدث ، ولا يزال من غير الواضح في
ذا الوقت ما إذا كانت هذه ال
وات الروسية والروسية من ال
حتمل جدًا أن يكون الأمر كذلك  لأن
هذين الجيشين يعملان بشكل وثيق
مع بعضهما البعض وكانا
يتدربان مع بعضهما البعض لفترة
طويلة من الوقت ولمجرد
إعطائك فكرة ، لا
تتحدث عن الحجم المحتمل للقوة
التي نتحدث عنها
حوالي 30000 جندي روسي فقط داخل
بيلاروسيا يُزعم أنهم قاموا بهذه التدريبات ومن
ثم بالطبع لديك أيضًا
جيش بيلا الروسي بأكمله أيضًا ، ومن المؤكد أن
هذا تطور خطير للغاية
نتطلع إليه
وبالتأكيد يوسع الهجوم الذي
يجري  أه ضد أوكرانيا في هذه
المرحلة من الزمن لأن
هاتين قوتان
هائلتان بالطبع لا أعرف ما إذا كان بإمكاننا رؤية
حركة المرور هناك
تنخفض مصابيح السيارة الأمامية  هذا الطريق الرئيسي ،
هل يمكنك أن ترى أنه نعم يمكننا أن نرى
أن حركة المرور كلها تسير في اتجاه واحد
وأن هذا
الطريق الرئيسي مزدحم تمامًا وهذا الاتجاه هو الغرب
وبالتالي يمكنك رؤية سكان كييف
يبدو أنهم يركبون سياراتهم
الإستماع لتلك الإنفجارات
المصحوبة بهذه الإنفجارات الجوية إركب
صافرات الإنذار الآن
والقيادة بأسرع ما يمكن إلي
الغرب بإتجاه أه المناطق الأكثر أمناً إذا
أردت من البلاد ربما بإتجاه
بولندا التي تبعد ثلاث أو أربع خمس
ساعات أه
من  هنا ولكن يمكنك أن ترى أنه تقريبًا
تدفق مستمر
لحركة المرور ، حيث يتحرك سكان هذا البلد
نحو الغرب في الاتجاه
المعاكس لروسيا ، إنه
مشهد فوضوي مطلق ومطلق هناك
على الطريق على الطريق
بنيتنا التحتية وحدودنا  المناطق
التي سمعنا فيها انفجارات ، نحن نطبق
الأحكام العرفية على
أراضي ولايتنا منذ دقيقة واحدة لقد تحدثت
مع الرئيس
، لقد بدأت الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية بالفعل
أه بتوحيد أه الدعم الدولي
اليوم
منك من كل واحد منكم
نحتاج
أن يبقى الناس هادئين وربما نبقى في
البيت نحن نعمل الجيش يعمل
قطاع الأوراق المالية بأكمله من
دفاع أوكرانيا يعمل لا
داعي للذعر نحن أقوياء  نحن ننتظر
أي شيء
سنهزمه الجميع لأننا
مجد أوكرانيا لأوكرانيا